نحييكم متابعينا من جديد وكان ورطات
الرئيس الامريكي بايدن تتلاحق وتتراكم
اخرها كانت قضيه الوثائق السريه التي عثرت
بحوزته والتمازلت محله جدلا كبير ففي
الوقت الذي تستمر النقاشات عن الاسباب
والتداعيات والعواقب الخاصه بملف الوثائق
السريه ينقضوا الجمهوريون على ملف اخر
وربما على ماء زق جديد
هذه المره ابن الرئيس الامريكي قد يكون
مورطا في استخدام نفوذه لبيع لوحاته
الفنيه وباسعاره باهضه هذا ما يطالب
الجمهوري هنا بتحقيق فيه بحسب
من جهتها جددت لجنه مجلس النواب الى
الرقابه طلب الجمهوريين للتحقيق في
المعاملات التجاريه لابن الرئيس
وقد قال جيمس كومار رئيس مجلس اداره شركه
هانتربوي ان الاخيره يتلقى مبالغه الى من
المال مقابل اعماله الفنيه تمام انه مبتدئ
ورقه ضغط جديد للجمهوريين على بايدا ابن
الرئيس الامريكي كان هدفا المفضلا
للجمهوريين فيما يتعلق بعمله السابق مع
شركات الاجنبيه لكنه اليوم اصبح عرضه
لتحقيق جديد بسبب معرض فني يقدم لوحات
تحمل توقيعه الجمهوريون يسعون لاثبات ان
الباحثين عن النفوذ هم من قاموا بشراء
اعمالها
بهدف التقرب من الرئيس للحصول على
امتيازات بعض اللوحات المعروضه وصل سعرها
الى
225,000 دولار
هناك هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من واشنطن
حسين عبد الحسين الباحث في مؤسسه الدفاع
عن الديمقراطيه اهلا بك ومن واشنطن كذلك
ايهاب عباس المحلل السياسي اهلا بكما
اسمحالي ان ابدا معك دكتور حسين في
الواقعه يقول مثلا او مش المثل يعني
العباره تقول مش ناق مش ناقص الا هالموضوع
الا الموضوع اللوحات الفنيه التابعه لابنه
حتى يطرح سيجال جديد وجدل جديد داخل اوساط
الجمهوريين وحتى الديمقراطين هل يمكن
الحديث دكتور حسين عن ازمه حقيقيه
مساء الخير ستريم لا اعتقد انه هذه
اللوحات يعني طبعا هي اليوم في الاخبار
ولكن لا اعتقد انها مشكله ستكون معقده
باعتقاد ان هناك مشاكل كثيره يمكن ان
تواجه الرئيس
خصوصا في مواضيع تتعلق بالوثائق السريه
التي تم الكشف عنها
وغيرها ولكن هذا الموضوع بالخصوص اعتقد
انه ليس الاقوى انه هذا الموضوع
لا يوجد اختراق واضح للقانون انه قد يقول
طيب انه مع انه مبتدا ولكن هذا الفن يعني
يسوى نص مليون او حتى مليون لا يوجد
اختراق واضح للقانون انه نحن نعرف انه
رئيس مركز دكتور حسين نحن لم نراه مبتدئين
يبيعون بما قيمته
225,000 دولار
يعني بحثت حتى ارى نوع او شكل هذه اللوحه
لم ارى منها على مواقع على الانترنت لا
اعلم استاذ حسين او كذلك استاذ ايهاب ان
شاهدته مثل هذه اللوحات ولكن لوحات مبتدئ
تباع ب 225,000 دولار غريب شويه الموضوع
يعني
الذوق هو في عين اصحابه يعني كل لكل منا
ذوق ولا يمكن الحكم عليه ولكن انا اقول
انه الرئيس بايدي نحن نعرف انه هو سيقدم
وثائق الضرائب السنويه كما على غرار
الرؤساء والمرشحين للرئاسه وهذا ما يعفيه
او يعني ما يخرجه من دائره الشبهات من
ناحيه التداولات الماليه يعني ان كان هناك
تجاوزات لهامتر بايدن يمكن معرفه ان كانت
هذه الاموال تصل الى الرئيس
اما في حاله ترامب هو لم يكشف عن الضرائب
ولذلك يعني هذه المواضيع كانت تاخذ
همم استاذ ايهاب هل تعتقد بان الجمهوريين
سيقضون هذه المره على هذه الفرصه وحتى وان
لم تكن ازمه كبيره ولكن يمكن ان همم
يسعى والربح بعض النقاط انصح التعبير
نعم اهلا بحضرتك واهلا بالضيفه بكل
المشاهدين بدايه يعني قبل ان اجيب على هذا
السؤال يعني كلنا من المفترض ان نبدا
بالرسم لانها فرصه لصنع مئات الالاف
كيميائي
الله يعطيني مذوقين يعني ويقدروا ههه
تفضل ههه
لنقل انا اتفق مع الضيف همم الاستاذ حسين
ان ااه هو الموضوع ليس كبير حتى الان ولكن
هو سيعده همم مكعبا في البناء الذي يبنيه
الجمهوريون ضد الرئيس
علامات استفهام كثيره منذ كان والده نائبا
للرئيس همم الاسبق برك اوباما وحتى خروجه
من البيت الابيض انا ذاك همم ومن ثم
العوده كرئيس هانتر بان يعني هناك لا اريد
ان اقول ان هناك ادانات ولكن هناك اتهامات
ومحاولات للادانه بانه استغل نفوذه في
اوكرانيا وان الرئيس نفسه عندما كان نائبا
الرئيس الاسبق باراكوباما يبدو انه هناك
اتهامات اقول مره اخرى همم كانت هناك
محاولات لتسهيل اعمال هنتر هل سيستطيع
الجمهوريون اثبات لهذه التهم بنفس الطريقه
التي اتحدث دائما بها عن الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب برغم من كل محاولات ادانته
الا انها حتى الان لم تنجح اا اتحدث عن
محاله المتعلقه بالوثائق المتعلقه بتدخلات
روسيا الى اخره ودائما تخرج التحقيقات في
مصلحته من الممكن ان يكون الامر كذلك
بالنسبه
لانتربايتن كيف سيؤثر هذا على مستقبله
السياسي الرئيس اذا ما تمت ادانه ابنه او
تمت ادانته هو سيكون هو نفس القرار
والمصير المتعلق بالرئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب اذا ما نجح
الديمقراطيون في ادانته ووزاره
دكتور حسين
ممكن فتح تحقيق فعلي اليوم هل يمكن
الجمهوريين ان يطرح هذه الفكره وان ينجحوا
في فتح تحقيق فعلي عن ملف ابن بيضا
لا اعتقد انهم بحاجه لتحقيق فعل يكفي
تشويه الصوره وتشويه السمعه ورب ذلك
بالرئيس غدا طبعا هو هانتر بايدن يعني
يعاني من مشكله اصلا بغض النظر عن رئاسه
ابيه او حتى عندما كان الاب في مركز نائب
رئيس هو كان يعاني من ادمان همم المخدرات
وهو يعني كان هناك فضيحه داخل عائله بايضا
عندما قام بزواج همم يعني ارمله
المتوفي وهو يعني كان هناك موضوع اللاب
توب الذي تم العثور عليه ويعني هناك ايضا
اتهامات ان هو متورط باستغلال نفود في
شركه صينيه او اوكرانيه ولذلك يرى
جمهوريون انه هذه هناك امكانيه كبيره
لاستغلال هذه الشخصيه
التي تعاني اصلا كصوره كصوره اخلاقيه يمكن
استغلال هذا الفشل الاخلاقي وربطه بالرئيس
الامريكي ولكن هل ينج قربت اعتقد انه هنا
هنا السؤال هم سيحاولون الدفع على الاقل
تشويه الصوره على امل انه يوما ما يعني
يعثرون على على رابط بين الاثنين يمكن ان
يسهل بعضعه بايضا الرئيس لمصلحه المرشح
الجمهوري في الانتخابات الرئاسه
ايهاب هل ينجح يعني
ابدا معك مما ختم به
وهو استاذ حسين
والجمهوريون في اقتناق هذه الفرصه في
محاوله همم يعني احداث اقترابات على مسار
بيضا القادم خاصه
لولايه جديده
يعني لنقل ان كل
اتهام وادانه تبدا بخيط والجمهوريون اليوم
لديهم هذا الخيط معهم
يعني هذه المساله المتعلقه
بالرسومات التي اللوحات التي رسمها هانتر
بايدن يستطيعون ان يتعاقبوا هذا الخيط
لديهم اليوم سيطره في مجلس النواب همم
هل هذه المواضيع تؤثر سواء في الاوساط
السياسيه او في الاوساط الشعبيه هل قدره
ان تؤثر في مزاج همم
يعني اقيس على ذلك ما حدث مع الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب فيما يتعلق
بالتهامات التي وجهت له ابان حكمه بانه
استعاون مع روسيا او سهل لهم
يعني انه يعمل ريتشنج للانتخابات
يتم الخوض في الانتخابات الامريكيه بشكل
غير قانوني من قبل الروس هل هذه الاتهامات
همم تمت ادانه الرئيس بناء عليها في اخر
المطاف نتذكر همم لجنه مولر التي خلقت الى
انه لا توجد اي تهامات توجه للرئيس دونالد
ترامب كانت هذه اللجنه معينه من
الديمقراطيين ولكن اساءت لسمعه الرجل عن
احداث الكابيتول بعد ذلك التي من الممكن
ان يكون فيها اتهامات للرئيس لكن كما قال
الضيف فكره تشويه السومه من الممكن ان
يستغل الجمهوريه
في كل هذا الاستاذ حسين من كثره ما نستمع
لقصص ت بعيدا همم تخص بعض الفضائح وبعض
الماذن همم البعض لا يتسائل ان لم يكن
وراء كل هذا بعض الديمقراطيين هم من يفشون
بعض هذه القصص لاضافه هل هذا وارد باختصار
لا يوجد اجماع حول بيض داخل الحزب
الديمقراطي ولكن لا اعتقد انه الانقسام
يؤدي الى محاوله ضاضا
لعلمهم انه ان لم يتنحب ايضا من الصعب
شكرا
في الانتخابات
الاستاذ ايهاب عباس المحلل السياسي شكرا
جزيلا لكم
السلام عليكم